[Music]
welcome to GameSpot's III 2018 stage I
am here today with Dan Edelman PR for
chasm how are you today I'm doing great
how are you I'm doing great too I'm very
excited to see chasm I've followed it
for a few years and I I'm feeling like
we might finally be getting close to
actually getting to play it absolutely
and and yeah this is actually gonna be
the first time I mentioned this publicly
in any way but the game is done we are
in certification with Sony right now
we're gonna be working with them to
confirm a release date but yeah it's
gonna we're gonna launch on Steam ps4
and Vita so if you're a steam player
people can just add it to their wish
lists and then ps4 and Vita will be
announcing the release date fairly soon
so yeah it's finally it's been in
development for almost six years now and
so it's been a long road but I think
everyone's gonna be really thrilled with
what they see like all the passion and
work that went into it I think it's
really gonna pay off
excellent well let's take a look awesome
all right so tell me what exactly is
chasm so chasm is a Metroidvania it's
more on the vania side of the equation
than the metroid side so I don't know if
you're aware but I also worked on axiom
verge which was much more Metroid II in
its in its content and this is more
vania
so in chasm you are start as a new
recruit who is sent to a mining town
because the mines stopped working and
the mines are critical for the outpost
where you live so you are sent to
investigate and then you find that it's
kind of a ghost town so no one's home no
one's around and then you are able to
talk to one person who's still left and
says that tells you that they were
trying to expand the mine when they blew
out one wall all these supernatural
creatures started coming out of the
woodwork so now your mission has kind of
changed in scope a little bit that you
have to find out where did these
monsters come from how do you rescue all
those villagers who have gone missing
and yeah and how do you save the day so
that's kind of the story to it
so is it all procedurally generated
dungeons yes so the way that part works
is all of the all of the rooms are hand
designed but when you start up a new
campaign and I can actually show this
really quickly you'll see in the bottom
right of the screen and has a seed
number that seed number it creates a
unique world map that's that's just for
you
and so one of the reasons that we
decided to do that is that a lot of us
have played
Castlevania Symphony of the Night Super
Metroid all these games over and over
and you know the fun part about starting
up a new game of those is the
exploration so how do you navigate the
terrain how do you get past these
different roadblocks that you couldn't
get past before and and how do you get
to where you need to go and so one of
the problems though is if you've played
those games over and over you kind of
memorize the map and you know exactly
where you need to go next so one of the
nice things about chasm so here's a
here's an area where I can't access yet
so I'm gonna have to remember to come
back to that when I get a powerup later
is that you can have that fresh
experience every time you play where
it's a new world map where you're
exploring all over again
but that said if you like the world map
that you first played on and you just
want to get like really good at it like
you're a speed runner and you just want
to hone your skills on this one map and
you like the fact that you've memorized
the map you can manually enter in that
same seed number and you'll get the same
exact map as the time before so you know
I I've been following this game since
before it was in Kickstarter and this is
actually an area that is very familiar
to me
do you ever get out of these mines or is
it a very mind focused game you are
underneath this town the entire game so
yeah there's multiple areas and the
deeper into the game that you explore
the
areas that you'll find so the mines are
where you start but later on some of the
areas that we've shown publicly there's
a gardens area which has this lush green
to it and there's catacombs that we've
shown before which has a little bit of
McCobb you know lots of skeletons all
over the place kind of feel and then
some areas that we haven't shown
publicly before and don't want to spoil
them here
absolutely and and the I mean the
Castlevania influences are very apparent
and like you said with axiom verge being
much more Metroid in this being much
more vania I have to you know kind of
wonder can you find a whip there I can
neither confirm nor deny that there is a
whip but yeah there's what excellent I'm
very glad to hear that I'm a big whip
guy there's a bunch of weapon types in
the game so yeah so whips are one of
them but everyone really has their own
favorite kinds of weapons and everyone's
play styles a little bit different so
some weapons are more powerful but slow
and some are more you know fast and have
longer reach that kind of thing
so this is one of the townspeople that I
just rescued and she runs a small magic
shop and so when I go back to the town
later on I'll be able to she'll be able
to help me upgrade my magic items and so
so the more townspeople you find along
your journey it's optional to rescue all
of them because some of them are hidden
in hard to find places off of the path
of what you need to do to finish the
game and find the you know the final
boss but if you find them all they all
add a little bit to the story of course
but then also they give you some side
quests and so it's it's a lot of more of
a rich experience than than your typical
Metroidvania where it's really about you
know how do you solve how do you clear
your primary mission there's a lot of
optional things to do for people who who
really want to go a little bit further
into the
into the depths of the dungeon and get a
hundred percent so this game was in
Kickstarter and it's been a while since
since it was successfully funded but the
I mean James and the rest of the team
have been super super super open and
they've released a lot of updates and
they've actually been doing betas how
has that actually helped with
development having the community kind of
like take part in it it's our community
has been fantastic so like when we first
started the Kickstarter and this was
about five years ago now we naively
thought that it would take about a year
because we we had this demo that was
that a lot of people played and really
enjoyed and it showed just kind of like
one subsection of the minds area so
people who backed the Kickstarter might
be like oh yeah I I saw this you know
five years ago but what we found is you
know as you get deeper in it's not just
make five more of those and you're done
or however many more and you're done
it's it's really about building all the
infrastructure to make sure that it all
works well together
so yeah our community every time we're
you know I meet someone at PAX who tells
me that they're a backer
you know I always you know apologize for
how long it's taking you know we really
want to make sure that we we do it right
and we do the concept justice and we're
not just like shipping out a broken game
and everyone you know without fail
kind of subscribes to the same mantra we
do of like a good game a late game will
eventually ship but a bad game will be
bad forever so oops no no well I mean
that's something that's probably gonna
happen a bit in the game so we might as
well show off all of the features
yes exactly death being being one of
them so when you die oh so there's
actually checkpoints yeah you go back to
the last place where you save so
fortunately that wasn't too long ago and
here's the map of where I am so I didn't
lose too much progress
so yeah that was deliberate where I
could show you what happens when you die
yeah totally deliberate it was
definitely not a mistake at all not at
all not at all
so yeah so yeah so without fail our
backers have been super supportive
they've proposed some ideas but for the
most part it was things that we just
wanted to do James has a very strong
vision of what he wanted Kasim to be and
so a lot of the you know time and
development was just him being very
particular about what he wanted the game
to be so and so yeah it took it took a
while for him to realize that full
vision but I think people will be really
excited to to get their hands on it and
play it the way it was always meant to
be well I'm really glad to hear that so
uh why don't you run down the platforms
that's coming to when abouts we can uh
we can see it and and yeah I mean I'm
very excited to play it so please let me
know when I can play it yeah so we
announced relatively recently that it's
actually so I just mentioned at the
beginning of this it's in certification
the game is actually now pretty much
done so we will be launching this summer
on Steam ps4 and Vita Sony has been
super supportive of of the game and so
we've wanted to support Vita and all the
platforms but eventually we'd like to be
on every system so not sure what the
timing of any other systems will be but
if there's a system out there we want to
be on it well thank you so much Dan I'm
very excited to see this game and I'm so
glad that you brought by thank you so
much thanks for having me